[Music]
I'm Anna Fox there are some things that
need to be said about me I have an
anxiety disorder I'm not prepared for
visitors I'm a agoraphobic I can't go
outside
[Applause]
[Music]
I've lived it
[Music]
you let some of the outside come in your
neighbor from across the street pretty
sure you're not supposed to be hippies
with alcohol my name is Jane Russell
she's become a friend like your earrings
oh thanks a gift from an old boyfriend
does your husband mind
family's complicated
I
[Music]
my neighbor changed she's been stabbed
my PD why is he here mr. Russell
believes that you made a mistake you've
never met my wife we spent the evening
together
I'm Jane Russell she's not Jane I know
what I saw the doctor said that your
meds
can cause hallucinations why are you
protecting them
they're all hiding something
her earring its move married house y'all
paying with their own family do they
know you're here alone
911 somebody hazing my house don't go
looking into other people's houses you
won't like what you see
[Music]